capitalism and money is the most pure
and Brilliant transaction it's the most
incredible system the marginal utility
of a cup of coffee for a coffee shop
owner is really low they don't want that
cup of coffee the marginal utility of
the coffee for the person who doesn't
have a cup of coffee is high and the
marginal utility of their £250 or $3 is
low so everyone wins isn't that
incredible think about that just for a
moment the coffee shop owner is so happy
that you gave them $3 for the coffee
you're so happy that they have this
coffee shop and that they were just
willing to give you this delicious
coffee and for $3 and you're like I
didn't want the $3 I didn't care there's
my $3 yay hot cup of coffee fantastic
and and then they're like Yay I got $3 I
didn't need that extra cup of coffee so
this is the beauty of business that you
essentially have two people who are
super happy super
stoked